I am Dave I guess I'm currently dating
someone so do they know I think so
are you dating no we're not I have a dog
that I'd rather spend time with that's
an indictment hi I'm John I'm a private
investigator in Los Angeles been doing
this work for about two-and-a-half or
three years now
today I'm to deduce which of our six
subjects are currently dating what's
your name
Felicia how old are you I'm 26 were you
from San Francisco California what do
you do I am a writer for BuzzFeed
calling it live in LA like eight years
you single yes
where you live around here Miracle Mile
Deena Ron yes apps yeah how's that uh it
can be tiresome calling it 'american Wow
um a year okay weird slip before that
santa monica go for that
sherman oaks for that koreatown
Hollywood
Lake Tahoe oh okay yeah all right when
was your last relationship like a year
ago what was his problem it was a very
long-term relationship and it ended up
just kind of puttering out yeah sorry
what's your name my name is Nate oh
where you live Glendale what do you do
I'm the manager of the animation
department long have you had the job
since March you did anybody nobody
specific that's nice beyond those apps
on the apps so when's last date you were
on three weeks ago how was that it was
okay
brutal we like to do for fun I like to
write and to listen to music you got
much live music I do ones last show you
want to this band called this wild life
what's that band called this wild life
they're good yeah it's just two dudes
since like third generation pop punk all
right focus up what's your name
Becky who are you dating no one okay you
can go now where do you live I live in
Hollywood what do you do I'm an attorney
where high speed let's go to law school
southwestern where you from Phoenix how
long you been in LA seven years in
change where you living away Hollywood
are you dating
no we're not um I have a dog that I'd
rather spend time with that's an
indictment of one's less than he gave
when did once upon a time in Hollywood
that's the last date I went on how is
that enough to make me put off dating
for a while
it was a guy or girl guy what was his
problem he was a little boring uh he's a
Red Sox fan and you know it's just
nothing clean what are you I'm a Yankee
fan from Phoenix well there was no
professional sports team when I was a
kid and Bernie Williams is the best
centerfielder even better than Lance one
dog Johnson I'm gonna go with yes what
do you think of the movie I liked it
better the second time I saw it you had
to second time yeah
how much longer after the date
immediately after no like two minutes
after okay what's your name Stan Lee
were you from Stan Lee
I'm originally from New Orleans
Louisiana where do you live I currently
live in Hollywood calling you have been
in LA
mm-hmm almost seven years what do you do
I work here as a video editor I
Yorkshire for since January so that's
six or seven loans were you dating I am
date I I guess I'm currently dating
someone's uh just someone that I've met
and do they know I think so okay how
long it's been about and be four months
okay what do they do
hmm they also you know do stuff well I
know you're full I just don't know how
that works out for me good or bad do
they have a job certainly hope so yes
what is it they they work at they work
at BuzzFeed how long you been dating
[Music]
like three or four months okay what do
you guys do for fun go to restaurants
and or watch movies what movies you
watch recently um that's upon Simon
Hollywood yeah do you think maybe a
couple weeks later she went back and
watched it alone again I can't I don't
know I don't know their life okay I
don't know what any of this really means
for me or my case it is kind of
entertaining
what's your name Stanley are you okay
alright why don't you come and join me
what's your name Lillian are you okay
yeah laughter is good we do it now in
Hollywood
do you live with Stanley I lived close
to him because we both live in Hollywood
a lot of people live in Hollywood yeah
well I don't have a car so I need to
live close to work and that's why I
chose Hollywood where's work here at
BuzzFeed mm-hm
what do you do I'm a video editor what
do you do for fun um I like working out
I also teach fitness classes oh yeah
look I like eating food so that's why it
worked out okay um I like K barbeque
soups pasta just miss anything
soups I love soups how long have you
been dating I'm not dating him
I'm not laughing cuz I'm okay what type
of workouts do you um I like swimming
and also like circuit training
what do you teach boot camp which is
circuit training okay I can get you a
free ensign if you want to work out
really yeah
you always bring people in okay yeah how
long have you been in LA three years
okay where have you lived besides
Hollywood
I'm just Hollywood are you dating around
yeah how's that going
um Ellie sucks for dating why lots of
actors models so they're not really
looking for serious is that true what's
your name like alright where are you
from a small town outside of Houston
Texas what's it called
vulture uh how long you been in LA about
ten months
and where you live he's Hollywood what
do you do I'm a video editor for Busby's
what do you do for fun like do like
athletic stuff hiking basketball but I
also like you know I have like a
addiction problem to the video games
what's your favorite game a Mass Effect
2 specifically not Mass Effect 3 not
mesnick's when it definitely not mass
spec for yeah Mass Effect here I can
count what's your kind of food I like
cheeseburgers
yeah you like movies I did I'm a big
movie fan what's your favorite movie
that's tough what's your favorite movie
Black Swan whoa
how long has it been since you last
dated like it were in relationship well
a real relationship like three years ago
so where was that relationship um we met
in Montreal then we went to Korea and I
want to come here so then long distance
didn't work out so you're dating someone
right yeah and what's this person's
story where does she live he or she live
Hollywood deal it together uh no no II
don't know do you write stuff outside of
[ __ ] I do you ever see anything uh uh
like short films hmm how's the sex in
your relationship it's up there it's up
there all right I think you can both
stuff away thank you
now I don't think nate is single but I
don't know much else beyond that hunch
just not really feeling Nate I think
Becky is a lawyer I'm kind of ruling
Becky out at this point I mean once
again I think the key to this
investigation is Stanley Stanley's story
is all over the place about the only
consistent thing is that if it's true
he's been dating someone for three or
four months but even that took him like
you know 60 seconds to finally come to a
decision what kind of food do you like I
like eating meat I guess in various
forms so I pick for him barbecue or
steak maybe Blake and Stanley are dating
because Blake likes burgers and steak
and potatoes and Stanley likes meat
I don't think Stanley as dating Blake
are you sure though I don't need that
right now Stanley could you come sit
here please
and Lillian would YouTube's here hi
could you switch seats real quick
actually please Felicia would you come
over here Lillian you can you can go
back I think you two are dating
really no that's true yeah yeah really
yeah yeah god I feel you said you both
have been in LA for roughly the same
amount of time seven years in eight
years I mean you both work here whatever
everybody works here I think I won
Stanley couldn't spin a lie to save his
life I mean it took him forever to come
up with any details so that put me on
alert to kind of keep an eye on you so I
knew Stanley was sort of the the key to
to the castle here I had a feeling he
was one of the two people there you know
you mentioned you've lived in in k-town
in the past
near the end you mentioned after meat
more specifically maybe Korean barbecue
was was one of your favorite things to
do and you lived in Hollywood as well
and you you say you've lived in
Hollywood I'm gonna get this is what
I've been told but who knows well I'll
tell you what you know I thought it
might have been Lillian - Lillian
Lillian and Stanley had the exact same
body language if I mean perfectly honest
I saw once or twice out of the corner of
my eye I saw Stanley shoot
Felicia a look when she was on the wall
and he was sitting here and it happened
more than once and I just thought I
think I think they're getting a kick out
of this more than other people I knew it
when he when I saw him answering I was
like he doesn't know how to
keeps calm under pressure that's why I
started grilling you about what you do
and what you create I thought well maybe
if she's a writer
maybe he edits her praat you know maybe
they met here or whatever met wherever
but maybe they're sort of a creative duo
as well I don't know if that's true but
you are yeah well then I should get I
should get two for this so I get two
points so anyway that's what I was
thinking
[Music]
you